The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at NCAA ocw.mit.edu.
GEORGE VERGHESE: I
wanted to give you
an overview of what the system
is that we're talking about,
the communication network.
We have a source that's trying
to communicate to a receiver.
We've talked about converting--
well, we'll talk
some more, actually--
about converting the source
information to binary digits.
And then where we've
spent a lot of time
is talking about
source coding, which
is trying to extract the
redundancy in the message
that you want to send so that
basically every binary digit
you then put on the channel
carries as much information as
possible.
So now I'm going to really
stop making a distinction
between bits and binary digits.
I'll just say bits when I
might mean binary digits.
But once you're
into the system here
and you've done
your source coding,
a binary digit carries
a bit of information,
in general, if you've
done a good job
of extracting the redundancy.
So we're talking
about a bit stream
here that you're trying to
get across to the other end.
At the other end, the
bitstream is received.
There's the decoding
step, which is
what we've seen with Huffman
or LZW, the decoding end.
And then you do
whatever it is you're
going to do in the application.
So we've really
said all we're going
to say about the source
coding and decoding,
and the rest of what we're going
to do is focus on what happens
inside here.
Now what happens inside
there at some stage
involves a physical
communication link.
So you might be talking
bitstreams at either end,
but somehow you've got
to deal with the fact
that most of these
channels, most
of the channels of interest,
they're physical channels,
they work with continuous
valued, continuous time
quantities.
For instance, the
voltage on a cable
might be used to
transmit information,
light on the fiber,
electromagnetic waves
through space, acoustic
waves in air or water--
in fact acoustic waves
in air is something
you see a lot of when you
come to the later labs--
indentations on
vinyl or plastic.
Let's see, that's
records or CD's.
And that actually
brings up a point.
We don't often think of
storage as being communication,
but storage is
really communication
with potentially a very long
time delay in the channel.
You put something on
the storage medium,
and then weeks or months or
years or centuries later,
you're trying to extract
that information.
So we can still think of all
of this as a communication
channel, and indeed,
decoding ideas
are essential to making
CDS work, to having
a CD resistant to scratches
and thumbprints, and everything
else that, all the
other indignities
that they're subject to--
magnetization.
So all of these
physical modalities
that are used to
translate information.
Here's one you may not
have thought about,
mud pulse telemetry.
So when you're
drilling for oil, you'd
like to get information from
the drill bit at the bottom.
And normal electronics
doesn't work
too well, because the
temperatures are fiercely hot
down there.
You need that information to
help you steer the drill bit,
to get information about
what sort of rock you're
going through, and all of that.
So they actually seriously
do use pressure pulses
and in the slurry that's cooling
the drill bit to try and convey
information back to the top.
So they'll modulate
the pressure down
at the end of the drill
bit, and hope that you
can detect it at the top.
One word over there
that stands out
is they talk about
digital information.
So even in the context of
communicating through mud,
they're thinking
about how to actually
have bits that they communicate
on this analog channel.
So this is very
much in the flavor
of what we're trying to do.
We're trying to communicate
digital information,
this is sequences of numbers or
sequences of signs or symbols,
but we're trying to do it
over a physical channel that
takes continuous valued,
continuous time, waveforms.
So that's really some of
what we'll be talking about.
So the kind of link that we
have starts off with bits.
But in the middle, has to
deal with the physical link
on which you have signals.
We'll refer to these
continuous time waveforms.
They're not always
continuous time.
You could sample them and
get discrete time waveforms,
as well.
But the signals that you
see in the physical medium
will refer to--
the quantities you see
in the physical medium
will refer to as signals.
You need some way to map
the bits to the signals.
You've got a bit
sequence, you need
to convert it to a continuous
time waveform in some fashion.
And then at the other end,
to recover the bitstream.
And you might do that by
some sampling and processing,
and then a translation
process back.
The little lightning
there is meant
to suggest that you're
subject to all sorts of noise
and disturbances when you're
on that physical link.
So that's something that's
critical to the design
of the system.
You have to design
your overall system
so that your robust to
perturbations in that middle
section.
So the particular application
is dealing with your specifics
and with producing
a bitstream that's
got the redundancy
mapped out of it.
At this point, it
doesn't matter to me
for communication across the
channel what that bitstream is
or where it came from.
I'm just trying to do a
good job of delivering it
to the other end where
the user can extract that.
Now here's the funny thing.
We've just done a lot of
work to extract redundancy
from the messages here.
We're going to put
redundancy back in.
Because the way you guard
against disturbances
in the channel is by
introducing redundancy.
You need to give
yourself a little room
to recognize that something bad
has happened to your signal,
or something bad has happened to
the data you're sending across,
and then to recover from it.
So we will actually
be talking about how
to reintroduce redundancy,
but this is introducing it now
in a bitstream where the binary
digits are essentially equally
likely.
You pulled out all the
application-specific knowledge,
and used it to do
the source coding.
Now you've just got a
stream of zeros and ones,
each one carrying a bit of
information, presumably.
And now you want to
protect it for transport
across the channel, and
you're going to do that
by putting in additional bits.
So you're going to introduce
bits in a structured way
to provide some redundancy.
So we'll be talking about
that in more detail.
So this is the
single link picture.
When you've got a network,
it's a little different.
So I haven't shown all
the other links here,
but you should imagine a
network with many possible paths
from a source to a destination.
Some of these links
might come down,
and so you'll want to
find an alternative path.
Some of these links
might be busy,
and you want to find
an alternative path.
So there's a whole
network of links in here.
In this setting, it turns out
that the good way to do this
is to break up your bitstream
into what are called packets.
These are maybe 1,000
bits or 4,000 bits,
or whatever your protocol is.
They're broken up into
packets of chunks of bits,
and then treated as packets for
transport along the network.
So the point is that one
packet to a given user
might travel one
particular route,
but another packet might
travel another route.
And then these get reassembled
at the destination.
So you think in
terms of packets when
you think in terms of
rooting on the network.
This idea of packet
communication, by the way,
there's a name
associated with that,
which is Kleinrock, again,
a PhD student at MIT
in the same golden years that
I keep referring back to.
But it's a very broad area.
So you've got the packets.
Those arrive at the links.
They're actually
switches here that
decide which of the links
emanating from the switches
you want to send the packet on.
So, again, imagine
all the links.
I haven't drawn them in.
So the packet gets treated as a
unit for shipping on the links.
But once you've committed
to a particular link,
it's like transmitting
on a single link, again.
So you've got to go
through your packets
to bits to signal to bits
to packets transformation.
So it's not that there's a
particular transformation
in going from packets
to bits, you're
just viewing it differently.
You're not treating
it as a packet,
you're looking in on each bit.
You're looking to code each
bit on an analog signal,
get it across the
physical medium.
So that's really
the key to this.
What we end up doing
is coding, or mapping,
or the word modulating is used,
and we'll see more of that.
We modulate the desired
sequence onto a continuous time
waveform.
So what you might imagine
is, you could have a sequence
01101, and what you're going
to do with your mapping is try
and generate a
continuous time waveform,
which in some fashion
codes that sequence.
And it could be very simple.
It could be a
voltage level of 0,
held for some interval of
time to represent the 1--
sorry, to represent the
0, held for some time
again to represent the second
symbol, which is, again, a 1.
And then you come back
down to 0, back to 1 again.
So it could be as
simple as this.
OK, so this is now--
you can think of
it as some voltage.
We use the word voltage
a lot, but we just
mean an analog signal.
We'll use the word
voltage, we're
thinking of voltage
on a cable, but it
could be any analog signal.
So this is really the
digital signaling end of it.
So you take the bit
sequence represented now on,
coded onto a continuous
time waveform,
or modulated onto a
continuous time waveform.
We'll see richer uses of
that word as we progress.
The particular scheme
I've shown here
is what you'd call a bi-level
signaling scheme, the two
voltage levels that you use.
We refer to that also
as bipolar signaling,
although sometimes
that's restricted
to the case where the two
voltage levels are opposite
in sign.
So you can imagine a
signaling scheme that
uses this for 0, this for 1.
So this could be
a bipolar scheme.
And then this
continuous time waveform
gets put on the physical
channel, presumably
gets distorted, it gets
some noise added to it.
So at the other end, you get
some approximation to this.
And then you've got to
reconstruct the bit sequence.
You might do that by
sampling this and processing
the samples, and then taking
some measure of the waveform.
We'll see more of that later,
you'll do that in lab 2,
in labs, as well.
So in some fashion,
you recover from this
your estimate of
the bit sequence.
But you can imagine, the
amount of waveform like this
goes through a physical
channel with distortion, noise,
and then re-sampling
and processing
and so on, you are
likely to get errors back
at the receiving end.
Ideally, you would get exactly
this waveform at the receiving
end, you'd have no
trouble distinguishing
between the samples
of the two levels,
and you could reconstruct
the bit sequence.
Now we are going to, in the
middle section of this course,
say a lot more about the
signals aspect of it.
But for us now, it's
actually helpful to stick
to thinking in terms of bits.
So we've got bits in, bits out.
Somewhere in here,
we've got signals
in the physical
channel, signals, noise,
physical channel.
And then we've
got whatever it is
that does the transformation
from bits to--
so this is some kind
of a transformer,
let's say, from bits to signals
and from signals to bits.
But let's look at an abstraction
that's end to end here,
bits to bits.
OK what's coming in as
a bitstream, what you're
receiving is a bitstream.
There's an idealization of
this channel that's used a lot,
and that's referred to as
the binary symmetric channel.
And what that says is,
you got a 1 coming in,
that's most likely going
to be received as 1,
but there's some chance it's
going to be received as a 0.
And let's put
probabilities here.
I think the notes use epsilon.
I seem to have used p,
little p, on my slide,
so let me stick to little p.
So a 1 coming in is
transformed in error
to a 0 with some
small probability,
presumably small, with
1 minus p it's intact,
and then the same
thing on the side.
A 0 comes in with some
probability, comes out as a 0,
but with some probability it
actually gets flipped to 1.
Now, we use the
word symmetric here
to say that we're assuming
identical probabilities
of going 1 to 0, 0 to 1.
You can easily imagine
an unsymmetrical channel
where you have different
probabilities in the two
directions, but we'll stick
to the symmetric case.
Binary, of course, because we're
dealing with binary sequences
of the two ends.
And what we're imagining is that
this is a memory-less channel.
In other words, I can
look at this transmission
by transmission.
So a bit comes in, this is
how the output is determined.
And then the next bit comes
in, and it knows nothing.
There's no memory
in the system, it
knows nothing
about what decision
was made in the previous case.
Now you can imagine more
complicated channel models
with memory, but this is
a good starting point.
So that's the binary
symmetric channel.
So question now, if we wanted to
get a bitstream over reliably,
any ideas on how
we can counteract
the effect of this p,
probability of flipping?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: You could have
like a range [INAUDIBLE]..
GEORGE VERGHESE:
Well, at this point
I'm back to the ones and zeros.
There's no signals.
The signals are in here.
So what you're
thinking of maybe is,
how do I reliably
map bits to signals?
And what you're saying is, you
can design your signaling here
in a way that reduces the p.
The p that I'm thinking
of here is the end
to end error probability.
If I designed the inner part
better, I might lower the p.
But for a given p,
is there something
that I could be doing to
improve my chances of getting
the bit across correctly?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: OK,
so the suggestion
is that we introduce redundancy
by just repeating it.
So send the 1, repeat the 1.
Repeat it many times
if you need to.
And so what would you suggest
that the receiver should
do if you do a
repetition like this?
How should the receiver decide?
If I send five ones
in a row-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: I'm
sorry, say that again?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: You're
talked about requesting a--
I'm not hearing well what you--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: OK, so
you're using the word request.
You're talking
about the receiver
sending something
back to the sender.
But if we're with this
channel and the sender
has to make its own
decisions about how
to get things across without
a possibility of feedback.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: OK, so I
think I understand a bit now.
So if you're repeating this,
the chance of more than half
of them being wrong
is very small.
I think that was the idea
that you had, as well.
So repetition is likely
to reduce the chances
that you go wrong here if
you use a majority rule.
Majority rule would
be a simple rule.
Send five repetitions, and if
only two are flipped, well,
you just decide in
favor of the majority.
Because it's more likely
that none or one or two are
flipped than that three or
four or five are flipped.
So that's the idea.
So this is what's called
a replication code,
and actually, it
can work very well.
So what you see on
the horizontal axis
is the replication factor.
You can replicate it 5
times, 10 times, 15 times,
and here is the
probability of error.
And it actually goes down.
And you can do the computation.
This is actually a fairly
simple computation,
you're basically
doing coin tosses
and seeing what's the
probability that more than half
of the coins I flip
come up one way.
And you're counting
that to decide
how the majority rule works.
I'm sorry, for the epsilon
here, it's supposed to be the p.
OK, so is this good?
Good enough?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE:
The more you send,
the more you're wasting
time on that one bit.
So this is the point, that
you can do the replication
and reduce your
probability of error,
but what's the information
you're getting across?
You're doing all of this to get
that one bit across reliably,
but you've got a lot
of bits backing up,
waiting to get across.
So the code rate, the rate at
which information gets across
is a 1 over n if you're
doing n replications.
If you're doing n replications,
it's only 1 over n.
The rate at which you're getting
information across in terms
of bits is 1 over n.
So you're dropping the
probability of error,
but you're also dropping
the transmission rate.
So this is really unacceptable.
It turns out, though, that
we can do a lot better.
We can do a lot better.
What I'm going to do
now is say a little bit
about what Shannon
had to say about it.
I hope you'll allow me to teach
you about something that we're
not going to test you
on just so you can learn
a little bit about this, and
then I'll get back to stuff
that we will test you on.
OK, is that all right?
I know you didn't pay for
this, but we'll do it anyway.
So here's Shannon,
defining something
that the thermodynamics
people and so on
didn't really think to do.
They may have done
it indirectly,
but it didn't arise in
where they were working
with entropy, and all of that.
Shannon defined something
called a mutual information,
given by this symbol.
X and Y are random
variables, random quantities.
What we know about H of
x is the entropy in X,
so it's our uncertainty
about X. It's
the expected information when
you're told something about X.
This symbol denotes
the uncertainty
in X, given information about Y.
So it's the conditional entropy
here.
And so what this is
asking is, how much is
our uncertainty about X reduced
by having information, having
a measurement of Y?
That's very relevant to a
channel where the input is X
and the output is
Y. We're saying,
we see the output
of the channel,
we want to infer what
happened to the input, what
the input sent.
The mutual information between
these two random variables
surely has to be important.
So what's the reduction
and uncertainty
that results from having
a measurement of Y?
That's a question
of interest not just
in communications as
such, but in all sorts
of inference questions.
OK, I'm going to have
a slide of equations.
They might look scary,
but actually they're
very simple, given what
you already know how to do.
First, I have to
define for you what
I mean by conditional entropy.
So I'm saying it's the
entropy of X conditioned
on having a particular
measurement of Y.
So suppose you know that Y takes
the value of little y sub j.
You use the same formula
that we've used for entropy,
except your
probabilities are all now
probabilities conditioned
on that information.
So instead of just p of xi,
you have p of xi given yj.
So it's the same formula.
But if you've been
given information,
then you have to
condition on it.
So that's the definition.
This is the conditional entropy
given a specific value for y.
But if all I tell you is
I'm going to be giving you
a value for Y and I haven't
told you the value yet,
what's the conditional entropy?
Then what you want to do is
average over all possible Y's
that you might get.
So you're going to take
this conditional entropy
for the given Y, and then
take the weighted average
of the probabilities.
So that's how you
compute this quantity,
and it's quite straightforward.
It's not very different
from what you have.
And then if you put in what
you know about how joint
probabilities and conditional
probabilities worked--
this was the definition of
conditional probability that we
had in, I think,
the first lecture--
you discover that actually
the joint entropy of these two
random variables can be
factored in two particular ways.
And that allows you to deduce
that the mutual information is
symmetric.
In other words, the mutual
information between X and Y
is the same as the mutual
information between Y an X.
So there's no
difference in that.
That might be a
little surprising
given that we were thinking of
X as the input to the channel
and Y is the output
of the channel,
but it turns out
that that's the case.
So let's actually compute it
for the channel that we know.
This is the binary
symmetric channel.
Let's compute the
mutual information
between the input and output for
the binary symmetric channel.
So here is the definition IXY.
We've just shown that it doesn't
matter which order you take it
in, and it turns out the
computation is easier
if you flip the order.
So I'm going to write
this as uncertainty
in Y minus the uncertainty in
Y given the measurement of H--
of X, sorry.
So I'm going to compute
it in that fashion.
What's the uncertainty in Y?
Actually, I should
probably have said here
that, let's assume
X takes 0 and 1--
I might be wrong
in saying that this
doesn't depend on the
distribution of the input.
Let's assume 0 and 1 are
equally likely at the input.
If the 0 and 1 are equally
likely at the input,
what's the uncertainty in Y?
There's a little
bit of uncertainty.
It's equally likely
to be a 0 or 1.
I had actually written
that assumption in,
and then I took it out, but I
think I'm wrong in saying that.
So here we have the 1
for the uncertainty in Y.
What about the
uncertainty in Y given X?
So I give you a particular
value for X. Let's
say X is equal to 1.
So I give you a
particular value for X.
What's the uncertainty in Y?
Well, Y is 0 with
probability little p,
and it's 1 with
probability 1 minus p.
And that's really the
binary entropy function
that we had drawn last time.
So you can actually work
out all these pieces
and discover-- let's see, here
is the binary entropy function.
Just to remind you,
this is for a coin toss.
If something can be 1
with probability p, 0
with probability 1 minus
p or the other way around,
the entropy associated
with that is H of p.
And we have 1 minus H of p
for the mutual information
between the input and output
of the binary channel.
So here's what 1 minus
H of p looks like.
All right, so what's
a low-noise channel?
A low-noise channel is one
with a very small value of p.
And what this says is that
the mutual information
between the input and output
is on the order of one bit.
So if you're told
what Y is, you've
got a very good idea what X is.
That makes sense, because
it's a low-noise channel.
But if you get to a
channel that has around
the 0.5 probability
of flipping the bit,
then the mutual
information is very small.
So it doesn't reflect
what you'd like to see.
Here's another notion,
which is entirely
Shannon, which is the
idea of channel capacity.
And what he's saying
now is in order
to characterize the
channel, rather than
the input or the
output, let's ask
what the maximum
mutual information
is over all possible
distributions
that you might have
for X. So I'm not
going to specify X being 0
and 1 with equal probability.
If you go through
that computation,
you find that it's exactly
the shape that we had before.
It's exactly, for the binary
symmetric channel, that happens
to be exactly this curve.
So the channel capacity for
the binary channel is exactly--
for the binary
symmetric channel--
is exactly this curve.
So that gives us an idea
of the maximum information
that you could be transmitting
across the channel.
Now that's just the
definition, but it turns out
to have some very practical
implications for how fast
and how accurately you can
transmit data on a channel.
And here's Shannon's
result. What he says
is that you can theoretically
transmit information
at an average rate below
the channel capacity
with arbitrarily low error.
So that's the shocking
thing, that as long
as you stay below
channel capacity,
you can transmit with
arbitrary low error.
If you try and get
to rates above that,
you're going to
run into trouble.
You can't get that probability
of error to vanish.
Now, how do you do this?
Well, the prescription is take
long strings of that input
message stream, take k bits
of that input message stream,
code it onto it n larger
than k code words,
send that through the channel.
If n is very large
and k is very large,
the rate at which you're
transmitting is k over n,
you can transmit
at a rate k over n
that lives below C with as
low an error as you want.
The way to make
the error smaller
is to take longer
and longer blocks.
This was kind of
an existence proof.
He didn't actually show
you specific instructions,
necessarily, in that proof for
how to introduce the redundancy
to make this happen.
But it was actually
a result that said,
you can't be satisfied
with the replication code.
You can do a lot better, and
how much better you can do
is indicated by that
channel capacity.
OK, let's come back
to testable stuff.
We're going to actually design
ways to introduce redundancy,
motivated by this
[? Shannon ?] result,
for very practical settings.
And a key notion
we're going to use
is that of the Hamming
distance between two strings.
So the Hamming distance--
you've seen this in some
recitations-- basically,
the Hamming distance
between two strings
is just a number of positions
in which the two strings differ
from each other.
so the Hamming distance here
between these two strings,
let's say string 1, string
2, is what, 1, 2, 3.
These strings differ
in three positions.
Another way to think
of it is, how many bits
do I have to flip in one
to get the other one?
So how many hops does
it take, in some sense,
to get from one to the other?
All right, so here's how the
notion of adding redundancy
comes in.
Suppose we have a 0
or a 1 to send across.
This is our bit for
that transmission.
What we're going to do is
actually code it not as 0
and 1, but as 00 and 11.
If we've got just a
single bit corrupted,
we go to something
that's not a code word.
We go from 11 01 or to 10,
or we go from 00 to 01 or 10.
We receive something
that's not a code word.
That allows us to detect
that an error was made.
So what we've essentially
done is, in Hamming distance,
we've introduced some distance
between the code words
that we're using to
transmit on the channel.
It takes two hops to get from
one code word to the other.
There's a Hamming
distance of two.
And, therefore, if you
only have a single bit
error when you transmit
on the channel,
you're not going to get all
the way to another code word.
You won't be at any
code word you recognize,
and you'll know that
you made an error.
So this is an example of how you
start to introduce redundancy
in the stream so that you can
detect and perhaps even correct
errors.
Here's another example.
Now this is-- these, by the way,
are still looking replication
codes because to send a 0,
we're repeating 0 three times,
and to send a 1, we're
repeating 1 one time.
But we're going to do more
elaborate versions of this
that are not replication codes.
But imagine now I've drawn
the corners of a cube.
Each circle here across an
edge is Hamming distance 1
from the adjacent one.
Right So to go from
the sequence that I'm
using to represent
to 0 to the sequence
that I use to represent a 1,
I've got to do 1, 2, 3 hops,
there's a Hamming
distance of 3 there.
So if I had only a
single bit error,
is it possible
for me to correct?
If I know that my errors are
limited to single bit errors,
can I correct when I
receive an incorrect string?
If I start with 000 and I
have a single bit error,
I can only go to these
adjacent vertices.
And those are not going to be
confused with vertices that are
one step adjacent to the 111.
So I'll know that
I've made an error,
and I'll know to
correct it back to 000,
provided I know that only
one error has been made.
Now, I might just assume that
only one error has been made.
And so once in a while,
I'll think I'm correcting,
but I'll be getting
something wrong.
And that has to be contended
with and calculated,
but this is the basic idea.
More generally what
we're thinking about
is taking key, message bits.
So this corresponds to 2
to the k possible messages.
We're going to embed this
in ended code words where
n is greater than k.
So if you imagine
a generalization
of this picture, what we've
got is a hypercube with 2
to the n possible nodes,
corresponding to all
the possible combinations here.
We're going to assign 2 to the
k of those nodes to code words,
and the rest will be
left free to just leave
some space between
the code words.
the rate of the code
then, the rate of the code
is, how many message bits
are you're getting across
on average per transmission?
And so the rate is
going to be k over n.
Because for every n
bits that you send,
you're getting across
k bits of information.
This k message bits and
every n transmitted bits.
So here is the general statement
in terms of Hamming distance
and what you can
do with the code.
So first of all, I've
got a set of code words.
What's really important is
what's the minimum Hamming
distance between my code words.
Because that's the point
of greatest vulnerability.
That's where I'm most
likely to get confused.
So if you give me a
set of code words,
I can look at the
Hamming distance
between any two of them.
I've got to search
all these pairs
and find out which is the
minimum Hamming distance.
That's the point of
maximum vulnerability,
and this is what we're
calling d, little d.
So the picture I
like to think about
is I've got some
valid code word here.
I've got some other
And if I told you
that over all the code
words in my set, the
minimum Hamming distance
I find is 3, what that means
is I've got to do three
hops to get to the
other code word.
This hop means I've changed
1 bit in the valid code word
to get to some other
sequence, not a code word.
And then 1 bit to
get to this one,
and 1 more bit to
and this is now another
valid code word.
OK, so if I say the
minimum Hamming distance is
3, that means that you
will find a pair of words
with these three hops to get
you from one to the other.
How many errors can you
detect with a code like this?
So you send a valid code
word across the channel,
bits get flipped, up to
how many errors could
you detect without being fooled?
If I tell you this is less
than or equal to e errors,
how large can e be
to guarantee that you
won't get a transmission of one
valid code word that ends up
as another valid code word?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: Sorry?
GEORGE VERGHESE: I'm
talking not about correction
but about detection of an error.
How many errors could you detect
in this kind of a picture?
So I can afford to have
one error, two errors,
and the third hour will bring
me to about valid code word,
and I won't know that
I've made an error.
So if you want to look at how
many errors you can detect,
it's what's given by the
upper one there, d minus 1.
So if the minimum
Hamming distance is d,
you can detect up
to d minus 1 hours.
What about correction?
How many errors could
you correct here?
Can you correct any errors here?
Up to one, right?
And then you can look
at this more generally,
and you see the general
formula is d minus 1 over 2,
the floor of that.
So that tells you how many
error you can correct.
So the minimum Hamming distance
is actually a key thing.
Now, how do you
build codes which
have desired characteristics?
For instance, suppose you
want to send 4 bit messages.
So k equals 4.
You want to have single
error correction.
So that means you want this
kind of a picture here.
You need Hamming
distance 3, at least.
How will you produce a code?
All right, so this is not
an obvious thing at all.
Here's an example of one that
satisfies the construction.
You need to actually
expand to sending 7 bits,
so n is equal to 7.
How many messages do we have?
We have 16 messages, so that
corresponds to a k of 4,
2 to the 4 is 16.
So we've got 16
different messages.
We could have counted
those messages with 4 bits,
but we're going to
add in redundancy
to get 7 bits per message,
resulting in these code words.
These code words,
this set of code words
has the property that the
minimum Hamming distance is 3.
So you can correct up
to a single error, here.
But it takes-- in principle,
it takes a search,
and it's not
necessarily easy to do.
But we'll see how to
do that efficiently.
All right.
Let me show you how-- and
this is something that
you're probably
quite familiar with--
how by making n equals k
plus 1, you can already--
suppose I choose
n equals k plus 1,
which means I'm taking the
message bit and adding 1 bit.
We're going to add what's
called a parity bit.
And you can do this in different
ways, but we're going to do--
let's see-- what I'm going
to do with this is guarantee
that the minimum distance
between valid code words
is at least 2.
So let's see how to do that.
And there'll be some computation
in not just the parity
calculations, but
other stuff we'll do
that builds on computations
of zeros and ones.
The computations are what
you've probably seen elsewhere
with Boolean algebra.
This is what's called
computation in Galois field 2.
So GF2 is another
symbol you'll see.
0 plus 0 is a 0, 1 plus 0 or
0 plus 1 is 1, 1 plus 1 is 0.
So this is like an exclusive
or addition, and multiplication
works in the usual fashion.
So all our computations
are with zeros and ones,
and you want to keep that in
mind as we go through this.
So here's what we do for a
simple way to add redundancy.
We'll take the message
and not a single bit
to make the total number of
ones in the resulting code word
even.
So this is what's
called even parity.
You can have the opposite
choice of odd parity.
So if you now
receive a code word
with an odd number of ones,
you know you've made a mistake.
How do I know that
the minimum Hamming
distance is 2 in this case?
I have to be able to produce
for you some other code word
that I've had with two hops.
Any ideas there?
So I give you a code word,
which is the original message
word with a parity bit.
Can I make two bit flips in
that and get a new code word,
I mean, a valid code word?
Because then I'd have
Hamming distance 2, right?
Can you think of what to do?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you flip
a 1 to 0 or 0 to 1,
then n equals [INAUDIBLE].
GEORGE VERGHESE:
But that's not yet
given me-- so the suggestion
was flip one of the bits.
AUDIENCE: So then
for the second one,
you'll either still have an
odd number or [? even. ?]
GEORGE VERGHESE: So if you
flip, for instance an easy way
to see this is flip
one of the message bits
and flip the party
bit, for instance.
No that doesn't do it, does it?
Because then you've changed
two 0's to 2 or two 1's to a 0,
and your parity is wrong, then.
So you can have a two
bit error that ends up
not being detected, but
all single bit errors
will get detected.
That, again, correlates
with the fact
that we set the minimum
Hamming distance at 2.
The number of errors you
can detect is d minus 1.
That's 1.
And the number of
errors you can correct,
well, it's d minus 1 divided
by 2, the floor of that,
and you can't
correct any errors.
All right, now we're going to
be building more elaborate codes
than parity or replication.
These are going to be
called linear block codes.
And there are different
ways to set this up.
Here's one way to think of it.
If you're comfortable with
the matrix multiplication,
here's one way to think of it.
And we're going to be
using this actually.
So if you aren't already
comfortable with matrix
multiplication, maybe you
should get comfortable soon.
What we have is a vector here,
which has our message in it.
So we stick our
message in there.
This is just a bunch
of zeros and ones.
I've got a matrix here, which
I call a generator matrix,
generator matrix.
And this is a matrix of zeros
and ones, as well, and so on.
So we've got things in there.
How do I generate my code words?
I just put in my message,
carry out this multiplication,
and see what I get
for a code word.
So for instance, if
I my message is 1
and all 0's, what's
my code word?
Well, I take this
and I multiply it
all the way through the matrix.
Because of the special structure
here, all of these are zeros,
so the rows below the first
one don't matter at all.
What I get for a
code word is 0101101.
In other words, I get
the first row of g.
If I had a 1 and a 1 with
00, I'm going to get the sum
of the first two rows of g.
And all of these computations
are done with the modulo 2
arithmetic, so in GF2.
So this is one way to think
of what a linear code is.
Another way to think of it is,
every bit in your code word
is a linear combination of
the bits in the message.
It's just that you
have more bits here,
so you're taking multiple
linear combinations of the bits
in the message to get the
bits in the code word.
So this is a highly
structured kind of code.
And the key fact about this is
that the sum of any two code
words is also a code word.
And we'll leave you to
look at that in recitation.
So it's true that any
code word generated
this way plus any
other code word
generated this way will give you
a code word generated this way.
can, you deduce from that that
the code word of all 0's has
to be in any linear code?
Why is it true that
every linear code has
to have the all zero code word?
In this instance--
well, you can see
it has to have the
all zero code word.
Why am I doing that?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE VERGHESE: Yeah, so
clearly from this picture,
if your input is
all zeros, you've
got to have the zero code word.
Can you tell me
from this statement
that the sum of any two code
words has to be a code word?
Can you deduce from
that the all zero code
word has to be in there?
AUDIENCE: So that's
[INAUDIBLE] subtraction.
GEORGE VERGHESE:
Subtraction or addition.
So suppose I take a code
word and add it to itself.
What do I get?
In GFW, if I take a code
word and add it to itself,
I get the all zero code word.
So the all zeros has
to always be in there.
If you don't have the
all zeros code word,
you know you don't
have a linear code.
Now it turns out that
for a linear code,
it's easy to determine the
minimum distance between--
the minimum Hamming distance
between words, which we saw
was crucial to establishing
what the error correction
or detection properties were.
If you've got a linear code to
determine the minimum distance
between words, you only have
to look for the distance--
the minimum distance between
the zero code word and all
the other code words.
So it turns out that
in a linear code,
the minimum distance that you
find between any two code words
is the same as the
minimum distance you'll
find between the zero code
word and any other code word.
Now what's the distance
between the zero code
word and some other code word?
It's just the number of ones
in that other code word.
So all you have to
do for a linear code
to determine the minimum
Hamming distance is
look at all the
non-zero code words
and see which one has the
minimum number of ones.
So let's see, it's not obvious
that these are necessarily
linear codes, but
they turn out to be.
In this particular case,
here's a code with n equals 3.
We've got only two
messages being sent,
so what's the value of k?
Two messages means k equals
1, because 2 to the k
is the number of messages.
So n is 3, k is 1, and the
minimum Hamming distance
is 3, which is the
weight of the--
smallest weight you find
among the non-zero words.
Here's another instance.
This is again a linear code.
Well, is it a linear code?
Yeah.
The minimum weight you see among
the non-zero code words is 2,
so the Hamming distance is 2.
So the way we denote this
code is the value of n
is 4, because there are
four different code words--
sorry, the four
different bits here.
4 bits, sorry, in
the code words.
It's not four
different code words.
2 is the value of k,
because 2 to the 2--
4 is the number of
messages that you have.
And the minimum
Hamming distance is 2.
So with each of those,
you can actually
compute the associated rate.
And just to wind up, these
are not linear codes.
How do we know they're
not linear codes?
Well, some two of
them, and you'll
discover that in
some instances, you
don't get the remaining
one in the set.
This is the code set
that I put up earlier.
It turns out to
be a linear code.
So if I claim that
it's a linear code,
can you tell me what the
minimum Hamming distance
is between code words here?
3.
You find a code word
here of weight 3,
and you don't find any code
words-- here also another one--
you don't find any code
words of weight less than 3.
All right, so this is
enough to get you going.
We'll quit with this, you'll
continue in recitation,
and we'll pick it up again
in lecture next time.
Thank you.